The sea has been pounding the rocks mercilessly
since dawn.
How much lies beneath that deceptively simple
word, the ‘sea’,
in truth a continuous
roiling evolving drama of a billion waves,
each one of individual character and rhythm.
Up in the cliffs is a cross section through
the earth’s autobiography: bands of sandstone,
siltstone and shale dating back to the Upper
Carboniferous period, 300 million years ago.
How long it took for us to make it here.
The sea’s rage and threatening power invites
us to a redemptive sense of our own smallness
and fragility: a bracing vastness that calms
and dampens our petty fears and egoisms.
- the indifference of nature as a relief from
being ourselves.
There are gulls overhead and large colonies
of razorbills along the perilous cliff-face ledges.
Every day they head out eighty miles
or more, diving 25 meters deep in to the Atlantic,
in search of sprats, cod and herring:
our
varied co-inhabitants in this otherwise deserted,
gaseous universe.
We are part of all this.
We should no longer say 'I' and 'they' - but
we. We should surrender our jealous, frightened
attachment to the human perspective - and
learn at times to merge with the universe,
to identify with its vast, impersonal forces.
We are the waters, the sky, the land, the currents.
At night, as we fall asleep, we can hear the
sea seemingly pulsing through our ears, our veins.
A little of nature’s energy is inside all
of us - and will continue its relentless beat
when we are exhausted and gone, having left
less of a mark even than the tiny trapped
corals and brachiopods in the rocks; mere
frenzied instants in eternity.